you speak of tough decisions the
commissioner may have to make players
have to make a tough decision so far
more than 40 have made that decision to
opt out for the 2020 season and there's
a looming dispute negotiation
point whatever we want to call it
regarding the deadline for opting out
now it's been 10 days since the nfl the
nfl players association worked out their
comprehensive agreement for football in
a pandemic the safety issues the
financial issues everything revising the
cba on which the ink still wasn't
completely dry from march
they basically renegotiated the cba to
allow for football this season they
haven't gotten it finished yet as they
haggle over language and the problem is
chris the way that they agreed to the
opt out procedure the players have seven
days
from the moment the agreement is
finalized well ten days after the
agreement was
informally finalized it's still not
formally
finalized and signed sealed and
delivered so the seven days hasn't
started yet and you've got all these
guys opting out
and the nfl now
wants to restrict the opt out deadline
so they're renegotiating one of the
terms of the agreement that they've yet
to finalize to give the players less
time to opt out i was told last night
that as part of those talks the nfl is
making other concessions and at the end
of the day it may be a good thing for
the players that they agree to move the
opt-out deadline to tuesday or wednesday
of this week and they get something else
in return from the nfl for it now
until we know exactly what else the
players get for that
i'll have no opinion on whether or not
that's a good deal for the players
because i personally think more time is
better than less time for the players to
make a decision on whether or not
they're going to opt out of the season
you want to be at practice you want to
be on the field you want to see how it
feels ideally you want to play in a game
ideally you'd have the opportunity like
baseball players do to opt out at any
time
any given day i can't do this anymore
i'm out the nfl clearly doesn't want
that hanging over their heads they want
to know who's in or who's out asap
and it could be that too that tuesday or
wednesday of this week is when that
deadline comes speak now forever hold
your peace you're either all in or
you're all out yeah well i mean it's
it's tough it really is i can see both
sides of the story here okay i mean one
when you first see it you go oh it's a
little insensitive come on these are
tough times let these players have some
time now they have been there for you
know we're getting what over a week now
to where they can evaluate it to a
degree as well but where i do have at
least a little bit of like
okay
sensitivity towards the nfl because i
don't think this is just like the owners
and roger goodell sitting there going
like we gotta draw you know we gotta
make less time for these guys to make a
decision i think they're probably
hearing it from coaches too who were
like well we'd like to know who's on our
team a week from now or you know start
building a team with okay here's a
deadline guys you got to opt in or opt
out okay here's the line now we know
what our team is they don't want to keep
guessing here and going well well we
might not we might need a whole new
right side of our offensive line we're
not sure yet but we're going to wait
until these guys make a decision so you
have to be sensitive to the nfl and the
coaches from that standpoint too and
that's where i get it a little bit i do
so i wish they could find some common
line here i mean you know not that it
has to happen tomorrow you know maybe it
doesn't have to be a week maybe just a
few more days but
i totally get the nfl's perspective here
but yeah you do have to be a little
careful here like you're saying i
understand it you know it is sensitive
this is not an easy decision to make but
what i will argue is it's different than
baseball you know hey baseball you can
go home yeah and you know okay they put
in a second basement and he plays and
then you miss a few games and you come
back and that's no big deal it's just
not the same as football there's more
moving parts there's more coaching and i
think that's where it's probably getting
a little tough for some of these
organizations right now
what i'm told is that teams have two
specific concerns chris about
this this indefinite window for opting
out because this again the seven days
doesn't even start to run until they
finalize the deal and finalize the deal
who knows when they're going to finalize
the deal and there's an incentive at
some level for the nflpa to maybe drag
their feet a little bit to give the
players more time two concerns though
number one
as players are starting to get that
sense as to whether or not they're truly
part of the plans for the season some of
them are saying i'll just take the
stipend i'm out i i hear you cut anyway
right i'm gonna get 150 350 000 if you
fall into the high risk category the
problem is and this i've yet to get a
clear answer to this
if you don't make the team next year do
you have to pay the money back now i
don't think the teams want to worry
about chasing around guys who got the
stipend this year to pay back the money
if they don't make the team next year i
think from a pr standpoint that just
looks bad that the teams would be trying
to squeeze 150 000 here and there from
guys who took the money at a time of
need as part of something that was
offered to them to get them through a
season without compensation without
being able to play football but there's
a sense that it's not in good faith for
these guys who feel
the acts falling on their careers saying
i opt out i mean it's basically the old
quit before you get fired and if you
quit you get yourself a nice little
package on the way out the door that's
one concern the other concern
and i have yet to hear of anyone
specifically doing this and i think
there's a pr reason for that
there's a concern that some agents
are using the threat of an opt out as a
way to try to get more money try to get
new deals try to finalize extensions for
their clients
but you know what i look at that and i
say hey for some guys
whether or not you get a raise whether
or not you get that new contract whether
or not you get more money
is a factor
in whether or not you play this year
sure if you're if you're saying to a guy
hey your salary's a million dollars this
year uh you have to decide whether or
not you're in or you're out a guy may
say well you know it's really not worth
me taking that risk for myself and my
family for that compensation with all
the other risks i take right but then
you throw on top of it a new contract
with a big signing bonus and an
extension and guaranteed money and this
that oh hey you know what it is i'm able
to take the risk now i mean that's part
it's a stew of factors it's not just
one issue up or down in or out a lot of
stuff goes into it and how much money
you're getting
and how much money you're giving up
chris has to be part of that analysis so
i don't have a problem with it i just
think the teams realize that you know
they're used to always having the
leverage on this issue they don't and it
makes them uncomfortable so let's slam
this window so these agents and players
don't have the leverage yeah well i
think as it pertains to
what you're you know that specific part
of the topic i agree with you i think
you know the nfl the teams for the first
time ever are like whoa
we don't have the power of the leverage
here the players do and they're holding
over our heads and i'm sure yeah i mean
i think it's a very real aspect i'm sure
that's going on behind the scenes
you know you know the other part of the
taking advantage or bad faith
it's something that i thought kind of
popped out right away you know yeah
you're seeing some of those guys who
you know again just to look behind the
curtain in the nfl team right 90 guys go
to camp
hey a lot of those guys know what battle
they're fighting you know that seventh
receiver or sixth receiver who's on
certain teams he's looking at the team
going well man i'm gonna have to hope
somebody gets hurt or two guys get hurt
he knows where he's where he is in the
pecking order and whether he's not gonna
make the team or is he gonna make the
team or what role he'll have so yeah i
think that has jumped out to me mike you
know guys in like year eight and nine
where you go ooh they could be veteran
you know casualties this year
and they're at a point in their career
where they've saved some money and they
might just go i'm not sure i was gonna
make the team anyways so i'll just take
the money or you see that you know
younger guy where you go i've never
really heard of him or he's not a big
name or i'm not sure he would have made
that team anyways this year and he's
taking it too and it crossed my mind
certainly but you're right that option's
out there so it's hard to argue it and
the nfl ain't gonna look good if they're
chasing these guys around to be paid
back next year so uh i think they're
just gonna have to you know swallow the
pill on that one
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports